في تطور اخر ضمن تداعيات الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه قال المتحدث العسكري
باسم انصار الله الحوثيين قال ان القوات
اليمنيه نفذت عمليه عسكريه ضد اهداف للعدو
الاسرائيلي بصواريخ بالستيه اكد ان
الحوثيين لن يترددوا في تنفيذ مزيد من
العمليات حتى وقف العدوان على
غزه انتصارا لمظلوم الشعب الفلسطيني الذي
يتعرض حتى هذه اللحظه للعدوان والحصار
نفذت القوه ارخيه بالقوات المسلحه اليمنيه
وبعون الله تعالى عمليه عسكريه ضد اهداف
محدده للعدو الاسرائيلي في منطقه ام
الرشراش جنوبي فلسطين المحتله وذلك بعدد
من الصواريخ البالستيه تؤكد القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه استمرارها في تنفيذ
واجباتها الدينيه والاخلاقيه
والانسانيه تجاه الشعب الفلسطيني المظلوم